[Music]
then there's the issue of you know a
shouting distance you know what a woman
imagine imagine here's the humans and
they go into this territory this
uncharted territory right or anywhere
I'm a girl
well no with the woman with a woman it
doesn't really you can put this in any
scenario you can even put it in Africa
and you can put it up on humans forget
about the Neanderthals I mean you know
no no lioness she's not gonna leave the
clan so far out and go all alone I'd say
I'm gonna wander through the forest
you know she's got no name one which
she's got no phone to call you know the
police's they help me know she's gotta
be within shouting distance of the clan
if a lion comes up you know and she
started she patty she said Wow yeah and
so the guys have to come in with her
ears and help her so so no woman would
would abandon the clan so far out you
know beyond shouting distance and so
here's this woman she's goes out there
how can she be raped assuming it was
rape right by an eMeter thought when
she's within shouting distance you know
these guys come with her spear those
spear this guy so it's not so easy to
rape a woman in the middle of the no
you're saying why they weren't
systematically raped on the borders
because women have to stay not only
women for that matter of men as well you
know you stay close to the clan you
don't want to go so far out that nobody
can hear you you're all alone
not because I'm a Neanderthal but a lion
Canada right so so the the
hunter-gatherer mind basal
hunter-gatherer things in different
terms he's gonna think of his own
security number one you know so he goes
out there he's got to be cautious there
is no phone no 911
you know you gotta go very carefully in
the wild and to think that a woman would
just go you know throw her her purse
around and go in the middle of nowhere
where an animal can pounce upon her you
know that's difficult to believe you can
you say this invaded us well yeah I mean
you can concoct many scenario what I'm
saying
all I'm saying is that we got to look at
the mentality of a clan whether human or
an animal doesn't really matter tigers
lions they all behave the same way in
this sense you know they have to be
careful out there because anything can
kill them you know here the lioness goes
out there suddenly you know a pack of
hyenas pounces on partner I guess
they're also she's gonna be just in
those words and those times in
prehistoric times they're always kind of
want to learn so you can't really say
that they were raped over and over
because it's like rape was the least of
their worries if anything they're
already under right Cillian things
there's nothing they're gonna get raped
just like that the other one about that
is that you know here's your Sunanda
though or a group of Mantooth around the
hunt they're going to look for mammals
and suddenly they see this group of
humans in their lands and here comes you
know a few males a few females maybe a
few kids are they gonna look at that and
say oh look at those beautiful girls
that are coming are they gonna look at
them as a piece of meat
Oh food she must taste good not me well
this is the point the point is would
they look at them as game or as sexual
object okay that's the case they would
have sex and then kill the girl because
they want to eat her maybe I mean that's
the best game but then there would be no
kids I mean if you spear the girl bring
her your spirit I don't think she's
gonna have a child you know yeah so then
there's the question of language how did
they communicate
I mean if it's consensual that he
doesn't consent you know beautiful words
in her ear and then you know assuming
the baby is born you know with the guy
with the Nanticoke of him in his arms or
dashing against the wall of the cave I
mean well because he said what did you
bring what is this I mean imagine
imagine what would come out of assuming
right a hybrid that comes out of an
ethical and a human female assuming it
could be the other way around army are
human you know suddenly assuming the
girl is pregnant right she's our human
right she comes back to our cave and
here's the husband would give the light
of he knows you can't really view the
human girl coming back and be like it's
your son where they are mad yeah I mean
something this you can attach them
against the wall ER is gonna cuddle them
say oh my baby
anytime you think of two species meeting
either you have to cut cut out into
reading you don't really that's not even
well you think I mean even when you
watch things like Star Trek and stuff
it's like Klingons yeah it's like I
don't know it was always unrealistic
when you see the Captain Kirk or
whatever flirting with these alien women
a completely different size what is that
well because he knows that they're
really Hollywood like oh yeah obviously
it's like you don't think of
intermingling or interbreeding when
you're talking about two different
species let alone two different like two
different of the same species
alright yeah culture stands in the way
strongly because just imagine these guys
the the humans they come from Africa and
they're expanding because I like they
they left their bags and they train
their Paris no it was an expansion slow
expansion over thousands of years and by
the time they reach Europe you know
assuming they encounter nanda those
they're now assuming they had sex you
know the question is you these guys come
dressed they're not used to the cold
they come from you know the equator
essentially and I'm assuming the
Neanderthals because you know they had
their grandparents the erectus and their
parents the high Goldbergs
and they've been in Europe for a long
time they got used to all this arctic
weather they didn't wear clothes so not
only were their heads a little different
but what was under their their necks is
also different because they're not
clothed
they're probably airy they're the wooly
man as I say and here's this other guy
coming with clothes because he's cold
their heads look different you know some
of them they probably have different
smells many things are different even
though they're the only clothes but he's
standing on two legs but other than that
there's very little you know similarity
and so the question is would these guys
invite them but they have a party or
what they look at each other with
suspicion about the party thing would it
would definitely be war
or rape but again when you're talking
about rape you would have to be you
can't really have systematic rape well
you can't have a rape like every week
kind of thing that doesn't with the
cheese with the chips go and invade the
guerrilla camp or vice versa yeah that'd
be weird
yeah and this is what we're talking
about like the chips go and then say oh
yeah so will you think of the geese that
work at the Max Planck Institute let me
tell you what I think
[Music]
you